charlie didn't get the memo no we're in
the purples with the sleeves
no the blacks without
he had to go back down and put the right
one on young right-hander tony gonzalon
coming back from some early season
shoulder issues will get the ball for
the dodgers
tapia will step to the plate left-handed
batter facing tony godzilla
godzilla one-and-one and a 2-8-3 era
opponents hitting just 213 against him
hasn't been able to stay in games all
that long as the dodgers are looking for
some length out of godzilla 3-2 pitch
swung on and a bouncer to the right side
of the mound chasing it as pujols
quickly flips onto first head first
slide by tapia he's out
good play by gonzalon to sprint to the
bag that'll bring up trevor story the
shortstop
story has become a big story
early all season long
i think they remain
and for how long i think a lot of folks
are i mean starting in spring training
began thinking about that because his
contract is up
and will the rockies get something for
him get some prospects for him or will
they keep him and let him walk and get
nothing
story pops this one up right side foul
ground pujols
over by the rocky dugout he's able to
haul it in for out number three
so for colorado in the top of the first
no runs one hit one man left no dodger
errors half hitting in the books it's
the rockies nothing and the dodgers
coming to back kyle freeland will try
and keep that mighty mo going yeah and
he's been really good over his last five
starts with that era about 2.25 one on
one out for aj pollock
rbi hit last night for pollock he's had
a good home stand a good month of july
freeland looking over at taylor at first
long long stare he comes to the plate
and did he go
he did down at first base jerry meal
said pollock swung and that is strike
three out number two
man two for five with a pair of runs
batted in last night hitting 389 in his
last five games
he's played second he's played third
and i've played them both splendidly
splitter hovers to the top of the zone
to ring him up first of the game for
godzilla
the batter is sam hilliard
on this 2-2 hilliard takes strike three
as it drops over the outside corner two
dawn nunez left-handed hitting catcher
strike three called as nunez got caught
watching a paint dry as a good splitter
by tony godzilla and he strikes out
three in the inning looking and walks
one
no runs no hits one left and at the end
of an inning and a half it's the dodgers
nothing rocky's nothing barnes in his
starting middle of the day but you
mentioned it last night what a weapon
he's turned into off of the bench he had
a pinch hit base sit and came in to
score the time run in the ninth inning
he's six for 13 with two home runs as a
pinch hitter
freeland deals and barnes hooks one in
the air down the line look out
it's far and gone
solo shot austin barnes and the dodgers
strike first
fourth of the year for austin barnes
it's one nothing in the second
noisy one for two off of the bench last
night
pitch strike three call there was noisy
looking for a breaking ball and watched
a fastball
power through for the out one out here
in the second tony has a couple of hits
in nine at bats one of the hits a double
2-2 swaying and a miss on a high
fastball
kyle gets his third strikeout but
surrenders the homer to barnes and the
dodgers lead it one to nothing the
leadoff man chris taylor for los angeles
to
get this half inning going
taylor bunted his way aboard really nice
bunt
third base side mcmahan charged in would
eventually bare hand it but throw late
over to first
and the 2-2 swing and a miss a pitch
down and dirty and kyle freeland strikes
out chris taylor runner at first bases
mcmahon
sheldon noisy the second baseman playing
up the middle outfield straight up
pelican center now takes a step or two
toward right center for the right-handed
hitting first baseman cj crone
stretch set at the belt kick in the
pitch and strike three called
godzilla walking sternly off the mound
of the third base dugout he earned it
as tony has struck out another man
that's his fourth
and ryan mcmahon left at first base
after a hit three and a half innings
done we'll head to the dodger half of
the fourth it's the dodgers one rocky's
nothing has went down looking in the
second inning he is over one
one two wave at a miss strike three gets
him swinging two down here's freeland
swinging a miss strike three got him six
strikeouts for tony gonzalon
that's one off his season high of seven
that he
racked up on the 25th of june against
the cubs
so tony gonzalez giving the dodgers what
they need through five innings here will
go to the bottom of the fifth
it is the dodgers one and the rockies
nothing
tony gonzalez counterpart faces kyle he
struck out against freeland first time
up
2-2
did he go
check swing they appeal down at first
and jerry meals said yes you did that's
another
check swing attempt that turns into a
strikeout for kyle freeland
five punch outs for kyle tonight
chris taylor
bunpays hit first time up struck out in
the third
the 1-1 taylor takes strike two that
pitch was in and down
wow and now he gets them on one that's
up
they're mad enough
as it was and now he gives him a pitch
at the top of the zone rimell has
grounded to first and
flied to fairly deep right field his
last time up
he gets a swing at a miss here on a back
foot breaking ball to get tapia
strikeout number seven one gone in the
six this will bring up krone who is oh
for two of the walk tonight o2
doubles up and finishes the night
back to back breaking balls sweet relief
a save for kenley jackson and a
one-nothing win for the dodgers
with the giants lost they pull within
two they've got to feel like a breath of
fresh air just hit him
and kenley janssen's 22nd save has to be
one of the sweetest he's felt this year